[Music]  when times are turbulent  politics need to adapt to reform  [Music]  there was a lot of turmoil in the  european union  in recent years there was a financial  crisis a migration crisis  brexit and on top of all that came  an unprecedented health crisis which  touched all of us directly it is time to  let people  take stock and let all europeans be here  we ask open questions to the citizens so  we ourselves need to be open also to the  answers  we will get even if if they don't  confirm  our own opinions our own view our  expectations  the conference is a way to make europe  stronger  and the message we give is we take  people seriously  in their dreams and in their entities in  their criticism  as well as their policy proposal so for  me this initiative is also a sign  of european self-confidence the future  is in your hands  you